سمعت الخبر أن
زميلنا بينما علم أه أن
عائلته قد قُتلت بينما كان يقوم
بعمله كصحفي ويقوم
بواجبه في الإعلام هذا
وضع فظيع وأه أه أولاً أريد أن
أعبر عن تضامني  مع
الزميل وأه إذا ثبت أن
عائلته مستهدفة لأنه
صحفي أه هي جريمة
فيجب اعتبارها جريمة
حرية صحافة واضح عندما تقطع جميع
الاتصالات أه يعني أن أسوأ
الأمور ستحدث وهم  إذًا
لا يريدون الكلمة تشهد عليه
صحفي أه الاتحاد والاتحاد
للأسف ليس لديهم القدرة على إيقاف
حرب ولكن أه يدعون إلى ضم أصواتهم إلى
الكثيرين الذين يطالبون بوقف
إطلاق النار أو على الأقل وقف
إطلاق النار الإنساني أه والممرات  لمساعدة
أهل غزة أه غير مذنبين في
شيء وهم ضحايا وأه
واضح أه
قطع الاتصالات هو وسيلة
لإقالة العالم ليشهد
ما يحدث أو ما سيحدث
الوضع الذي تصفه لي يجعلني
متشائم جدا أه وأكرر هناك
دعوات كثيرة لوقف إطلاق النار أو على
الأقل بعض وقف إطلاق النار الإنساني أه
لأن الأهم
هو إيصال المساعدات الإنسانية
للمدنيين في غزة وهناك
احتياجات كبيرة لكن أه للصحفيين
مرة أخرى يجب أن أكرر الصحفيين
ليسوا صحفيين مقاتلين يقومون
بعملهم أه جلب المعلومات
للجمهور وإظهار ما يحدث
وأه عندما تحاول إسكاتهم
هذا ليس رد فعل دي ديمقراطي وهو
أه لو دعونا نفكر في ذلك
الكلمات ستحدث أشياء